you know I don't know I mean there's a
whole talent III don't really
I'm not a big follower of leaders I'm
not a big advocate of the big powerful
leader thing I think it's about the
people who make changes or changes are
made every day by people who do the work
every day the kind of work my sister
does giving out condoms talking to
people to me those that's leadership and
I don't really expect a Wall Street guy
or Richard Park dick Parsons dick
Parsons can donate twenty million
dollars to whatever and that's great but
without teachers who what a day today
basis interact with the kids who were
spending the twenty million dollars the
twenty million dollars goes out the door
so I'm not I don't really give I did it
that whole thing the upper-class doesn't
mean anything to me I was I was raised
up by a little black woman you know was
two kids struggling their projects who
taught me how to read before I went to
school that's leadership so I don't
really worry about I'm not worried about
people I don't think I think that that's
a false actually even discussion because
it presupposes that black Americans have
a particular responsibility to poor
people that white Americans know no one
at you know just alone have a particular
responsibility to make sure that
working-class Italians and Corona you
know get helped probably not do rich
Americans have a responsibility to poor
Americans to help them get a more
equitable opportunity as country yes
that's the way I look at it I don't I
don't think I don't think poverty is a
black issue I think it's an American
issue
you